first up he is the author of omg what
the [ __ ] does the cotton well wtf does
the constitution actually say
a non-boring guide to how our democracy
is supposed to work ben sheehan
[Music]
ben
don't you get near me alone i promise no
i'm just kidding
so uh listen i'm so glad you're here and
i i
really mispronounced it i said omg and
then i went right to what the [ __ ] but
it's wtf
and those letters don't even really
correspond to what we think they are
although it works both ways obviously oh
my god what the [ __ ] but it's also ohio
michigan
georgia wisconsin texas florida because
those are the key states right you go
okay so we have a lot in common theme
wise we've both been on and on
for a long time i have anyway i know
about this problem we have in america
that you are such the perfect guest to
walk us through which is we're
on the honor system so much that we
depend on has not
actually been written down in law or the
constitution
and now we have someone who has no honor
puts his family in office
gets help from foreign countries runs a
business empire while he's president
things we didn't think we had to write
down
right so my worry now is that the
electoral college
it's not actually written down that the
electors which really elect the
president
go to the guy who gets the most votes in
the state right i mean
to start it's you only have you know you
have 17 states that don't bind their
electors uh including states like
pennsylvania and georgia and texas
make them follow the popular vote in the
state
so that's one thing that's not written
down they leave it up to the states and
that's what the supreme court decision
earlier this year said that it is
constitutional to have
a faithless elector laws and also for
states to decide not to have that
but so much of the electoral college is
is is said in the constitution but a lot
of the actual process that's going to
happen over the next two months
is set by federal law and even the
federal law that describes it people
could barely understand
um this section 15 written in 1887
is is constantly debated it's almost
unintelligible and so
my worry is if we get to this point
where we have the electoral count that
happens on january 6th
there's going to be disputes and it
could go haywire what is the
likelihood though that some state at
least one state
does not send to the electoral college
to meet to actually elect the president
does not send
electors that represent who won that
state do you think that's a high pop
i don't think it's a high probability
but i've thought a lot of things over
the last four years didn't have a high
probability that it's
happening so well one thing we know for
sure the one thing we know for sure
is that however much trump loses by and
look i was not sanguine last time and
i'm not this time but this time
you know last time i did not predict he
would win
he would lose this time i'm saying he
will lose
but that's just the popular vote and
probably the electoral college what i
know will not happen
is the next day donald trump saying i
congratulate joe biden
and i've instructed my staff to make a
smooth transition
the best man won and this is our system
that will never
happen right no that will not happen
so he'll lose big and then go ape [ __ ]
about that is my prediction what will
apeshit entail well my worry is is less
that his ape [ __ ]
and more of the people who are around
him who know the system
because what's going to happen over the
next few weeks is you have obviously the
election on november 3rd
but then you have until december 8th if
there's a if there's a controversy in a
state or there's a recount um
or claims of male voter fraud or
whatever it is there is this opportunity
for states to choose
to to decide a different way to appoint
the electors and as long as they act on
it by december 8th they could
make it go differently from the popular
vote so we have to pay attention to our
state legislators in that period
to make sure that they follow the
popular vote in the state so that we
don't have a popular vote
in the state that's different from the
electors
you